but for me living in Los Angeles I have
a a program a mine we practice at the
Mamba Center so I'm in the mob vicente
12 times a month
we play every other weekend at the Mamba
Center you did the hill that he the
fatality with him and the other
passengers is the hill that we run up my
son KJ Malloy we run up that hill well
they run our jog and they and you know
up that helped to get in shape it's the
same Hill so every site to me when I
heard heard it I was I was devastated
when my daughter Kayla called me and
told me because I first thing I thought
it was him as a family man cuz that's
what I'm seeing
I didn't think Lakers honestly I didn't
think basketball I was like this guy's
going to the Mamba Center because
there's a tournament there this weekend
that I know about and he in every soccer
mom every soccer dad could understand
that relationship that he's doing
I'll call pool is a minivan his was a
helicopter and he's on his way to play
and not only that he's on his way to
coach which is another responsibility
here's a guy who it was all about Kobe
for all of his life and we were seeing a
transition that he was putting his
family and his daughters up front you
know so when we saw the pictures of GG
we knew her because he was putting them
up front because they had been in the
background so long so it just as a dad
and as a family man that's my first and
not my first reaction was what was
Vanessa thinking and possibly doing
because that is the routine that every
soccer dad soccer mom does Saturday
Sunday you drive and you carpool to
these tournaments and you're only doing
it not to hope that your daughter your
son is going to be in the NBA
or you're doing it with the hope that
you have a memory with your kids he
bought him you think about this he
bought it a gymnasium an hour half from
where he lives you think Kobe Bryant
needs to buy gymnasium in Thousand Oaks
no to make money no you think Kobe
Bryant needs to have a tournament for
girls called the Mamba series no he's
doing it to spend moments with his
daughter and then he takes on the
responsibility of all of those other
kids because as we soccer dads it's Shaq
nose D way you know no your daughter
didn't play Charles but we we're in that
environment we're going like if you
coaching that team everyone says oh he's
coaching no he had to call everyone to
get on that chopper he had to say what
time we're gonna meet call the other
parents oh by the way where we're not
black uniforms it could be draining for
a guy who's Kobe Bryant but he took the
challenge and said I wouldn't be my mom
and mentality makes me a dad first and
I'm gonna show you how to be a dad I'm
gonna be just as aggressive as being a
dad and that was the transition that I
never said until even now I was like I'm
at miring and it's do like his
transition into fatherhood and you know
and just being retired and it just hurts
and that's what we all can relate so
what he was doing and why he was doing
it and it hurts what happened for me was
Ernie I was in the movies what this
autumn movie - gentlemen it started
around 11:30 you know they'd show a
bunch of previews I get out I don't
never take my phone - thither I get out
I turn it over
ooh 75 missed calls 100 text messages
I'm like oh there's no it's been a big
treat in the NBA then I started clicking
and I see died kills died killed I was
told something really bad had happened
and didn't I click to see it in
and I just thought of Cline I'm not
gonna lie I just started crying and I
don't even have that type of
relationship with Kobe but he was part
of the basketball fabric of my 16 years
in the NBA my 19 years on TNT I think he
was like one of my kids and I just felt
I just felt pain I did I just felt pain
I cried and I was like let me gather
myself and I said I said okay I'm not
gonna do any interviews cuz I don't know
what to say because that's nothing I
just said man just shut the hell up
don't say anything and I took the whole
time off and I said let me then I talked
to you I talked to Shaq I talked to
Kenny
Candace Parker sweet lady sent me a nice
check and then I started getting texts
from people saying man I feel for you
but they knew I don't even know how they
knew it
but they knew I was in pain I mean
because I can say Kobe you know one
thing about our business check people
want to know what's the wain way like
I'm like you know when they saw us
shooting around he's a great guy great
guy hit me Gabby fun to be around they
won't know about you know everybody said
what about coke I says I don't know Kobe
Kobe always walks up to me said hey
Charles how you doing hope everything's
good but he keeps moving and that's
happened probably 3040 times but I
didn't know him but he was always
cordial and friendly but I'm not gonna
get on TV and act like we hung out and
had dinner and we were good friends I
leave that to Shaq and II wait I can't
he talked about earlier and then the
second thing I sit there and watch TV
for like five hours and then it because
I heard the thing about Rick Fox like
Shaq said I went oh my god because Rick
working with us and then I started
thinking because you know for like X
amount of hours he said there was only
five people and then it was nine then it
was not then I started thinking man
what's the one thing I hate about the
media and I know they got a job to do
and we're part of the media I hate when
they do the kobe bryant and others
because those are actually real people
and my first concern man I I just when I
released my state when I said
don't forget these other seven people I
know Kobe AGG a part of our basketball
family but there's seven people you know
I know it was a mom and dad and a
daughter
yeah mom who had three young kids on a
husband at home and a couple more people
and I just felt bad for everybody and it
hurt man I just I just felt pain and
then I started thinking like man Vanessa
those girls and you know you know and I
made a mistake too when I released my
statement
I should have acknowledged I don't get
it anybody's personal business but I
should acknowledge his parents that was
a screw-up on my part I've known Jill
Bryan for my days of playing in
Philadelphia I should have acknowledged
his mother and father because I know
they're in pain also but I just man I
feel so bad for everybody who lost
somebody and I just feel bad
III put it like that I said people said
how you feel I said I just feel sad
that's all I could